so you just said when I asked you what
is Allah's Throne you said it's his
majesty you also affirmed that Muhammad
sits on Allah's Throne so that means
that he's sharing Allah's Majesty this
is sh Give me a definition for
associating a partner with Allah when
you say that somebody shares Majesty
with Allah then you're associating a
partner
bro hold it like
this
me I wanted to ask something based on I
wanted to ask the same question that you
asked to me like what would you see when
you see Allah what will you see when you
when you see Allah what will you say
mhammad sitting on on the throne of God
like said
that you that's an
argument he what's the issue that can't
be a counter that's not my argument
what's the issue with the prophet
sitting on the throne the issue what is
the issue God does mean his God
is on is the issue hold on hold on
there's definity say it again if you
don't got an issue with that I guess not
do you have an issue with muhamad
sitting on the throne I I think it's a
problem that a problem I think because
it's it's Allah's Throne right is the
throne is the throne created yeah but
it's it's Allah it's Allah's Throne the
throne cre do look so this is why I'm
saying this because the Quran says that
Allah doesn't share his authority with
anyone he doesn't he shares Dominion
with anyone but if Muhammad is sitting
on Allah's Throne he's Shar Dominion
right is the throne cre yes is Muhammad
created yes okay who the object of
worship uh it would look like it's both
if he's sitting on if he's sitting on
Allah what's what's the lab let him
respond the fake lab doesn't work here
who's the object of worship I just told
you okay if he's sitting if he's sharing
Dominion with Allah it looks like both
are the objects of worship refute that
beautiful you're saying Muslims are
committing sh yes okay when will
Muhammad they not sharing Authority any
I don't know tell okay he doesn't know
but he's making the argument no no you
affirmed it what are you talking about
when will Muhammad sit on
theoat will everybody be dead that what
I know will everybody be dead at that
time isn't that the day of res it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter why
even even none of being alive and is
still sitting on
every that means you believe that is God
who is the object of worship why why how
prove it because he's sitting on Allah's
Throne which represents Allah's Domin
yeah no who said represents Allah's the
throne what classical Arabic lexicon are
you getting this what is the what is it
the throne is a creation of Allah but
what is it what it mean it's Allah's
Throne look you're a creation of Allah
are you Allah's Throne no okay what is
Allah's Throne Allah's Throne it's his
majesty okay beautiful it's his majesty
sure so can any human share Allah's
Majesty the throne is created that's I
didn't ask you that can can any creature
what is the issue of mamed sitting on
let me ask answer the question can any
wait don't save him don't put your cape
on can any creature share Allah's
Majesty not Allah's Majesty who said
that Muhammad sitting on the throne is
sharing Allah's Majesty okay I'll tell
you how you we just broke it out I'll
tell you how so you just said when I
asked you what is Allah's Throne you
said it's his majesty you also affirmed
that muhamed sits on Allah's Throne so
that means that he's sharing Allah's
Majesty this is sh Give me a definition
for sh associating a partner with Allah
when you say that somebody shares
Majesty with Allah then you're
associating a partner bro okay
Beau like
this give me the classical Arabic Lex
definition for what sh
what why why talking
about can we just look we Ain got all
these books here can we just agree it's
okay we don't book can we just agree
that Shir means means the definition of
a classical Arabic lexican do it for me
no this is your job you're why why is it
my job why should I do your homework for
you no this is you you're telling me
that you're telling me that I'm wrong on
the meeting first you agreed that
Muhammad sitting on the throne there is
no issue we no I didn't no I didn't did
he not say there is no issue when you
said when you say that you don't have a
problem with I said well I guess not but
that's you but the fact is so if you
don't have an issue with shk that's
that's that's on you
[Music]